[Music]
top six best and worst things about
destiny
best gunplay considering in the same
company that created the multiplayer
genre-defining halo series this should
come as no surprise
Destiny's gunplay is top tier and you'll
struggle to find any games that run as
smoothly and consistently as Destiny's
gunplay mechanics
[Music]
worst story it's not the story itself as
bad it's the way they tell it it's as if
the game was created and the story was
written afterwards very little of the
story is told and gained through the
collection of grimoire cards
the story goes into considerable detail
however you'll need to go onto a
computer to view these or just find a
good YouTube channel who's quite
passionate about game law best reads six
player missions far longer than a strike
and with no guidance raids are PvE
at its best in order to complete the
most difficult and complex content in
the game teams required good
communication in a high level gear upon
completion players rewarded with loot
exclusive to the raid other than unique
weapons you're also giving some swede
vanity items to show off in the tower
however this brings us to worst content
being locked off to half of the play
base the best content in the game is
locked off to the majority of players
probably one of the most requested
things in the community is to have
matchmaking added to the race both sides
have valid arguments of whether they
should or should not be implemented
regardless Bungie has stuck to the guns
and will not be adding this to the game
this means teams of less than six or
solo players are required to find other
games using third-party websites
best build customization vanity one of
the best parts our destiny is dressing
up your characters to look badass more
often than not you'll see players
forgoing high level gear in order to
appeal to the vanity side of the bill
it's no shortage of variation and you'll
see a number of options pop up as you
explore the Destiny universe worst build
customization steps and diversity
possibly the reason Banerjee is chosen
over stet is there really isn't that
much of a difference between a god role
in a mediocre antes more variation
between gear would lead to much larger
variety and build options but this would
mean a lot more work by the developers
to ensure balanced
best end game content it's taken three
years and it certainly wasn't like this
in new one but there is a ton of stuff
to do with each weekly refresh once you
finish the raid in the nightfall story
missions and stripes can award you chips
that often contain exclusive vanity
items to flesh out your character also
available as a challenge of elders and
rotating crucible types
worst DLC content this can be a
difficult one for a lot of casual
players to understand but the days are
paying for the based game and nothing
else overtime are gone with genres like
MMOs and looter shooters there is a
constant need for maintenance updates
and extra content or the game simply
dies out in order to fund these DLC
content is released the big question is
whether the DLC content contains enough
to make it worth buying yet if you
decide not to buy you miss out on
upcoming events whether you're paying
upfront expansion packs or they're
funded through things like in-game
stores they are here to stay best loot
system there are a few issues of that
releases destiny but the rewards given
for the activities completed seem in a
very good place right now and there's a
nice balance of what can drop randomly
the only thing that is tendered the
enthusiasm the grime was the
introduction of three of coins these
lots of exotic items by making them part
of easy to obtain
wurst no dedicated service if sending
works on a peer-to-peer system which
essentially means that each peer
receives the input streams of each other
player and determines the results so the
more players the more raw input data
that needs to be handled locally this
can work well but not so much in place
in the game where others around the
globe we're connection quality very
quickly becomes an issue and short a
dedicated server will be the gameworld
hub performing and sending and receiving
of data minimizing the chance of a
single poor connection affecting the
experience of all players best social
areas whether it be in between
activities or right after booting up the
game the social areas latent hours and
never ceases to surprise you'd be
playing around various objects available
like soccer ball having a data file as a
leader or simply showing off your sweet
sweet loot and shares although it
certainly doesn't make a game it's well
thought out light-hearted additions
worst orbit if you gotta play destiny
you better get used to the orbit screen
ah you want to do a mission go to orbit
a strap go to orbit you want to join the
fire team of friends earning the same
calories you go to orbit and fly your
ass back down
destiny has been a well-received
successful game but certainly isn't
without its flaws hopefully with Disney
2 on the horizon the developers have
considered areas where improvement is
gieux but also haven't strayed too far
from the areas that they have done so
well
[Music]
you